after a dramatic escape and ten days in
hiding Carlos gone faces the cameras in
Beirut
the former Nissan Chairman now cast as
the world's most notorious fugitive
facing serious corruption charges in
Japan he says he is the real victim
thing I did not escaped justice I fled
injustice execution political
persecution having in your more than 400
days of inhumane treatment in a system
designed to break me and unwilling to
provide me even minimal justice mr.
Cohen is charged with defrauding Nissan
out of millions of dollars but he claims
a boardroom feud escalated into a
conspiracy by Nissan executives Tokyo
prosecutors and government officials to
kick him out and prevent a merger with
Renault there was no way I was going to
be treated fairly no sign that I will
have a normal life for the next four or
five years so I can tell you that means
it's not very difficult to come to
conclusion you're gonna die in Japan or
you're gonna have to get out how he got
out was the one thing he wouldn't talk
about during a two-and-a-half hour press
conference in an elaborate operation he
was smuggled inside this box normally
used to carry out audio speakers onto a
private jet that flew from a soccer to
Istanbul where this CCTV footage shows
him being transported onto a second
plane for the final leg of the journey
to Beirut he's now staying at this house
in the city which Nissan says he bought
for a company subsidiary Michael
Woodford was targeted by the Japanese
system after he blew the whistle on
wrongdoing at corporate giant Olympus he
clearly should be held to account for
the charges against him but I completely
understand why he felt he would not get
a fair hearing at a trial in a country
where the conviction rate is almost a
hundred percent close to 100 percent
what is the point of a trial
Japanese prosecutors say they will
continue to pursue mr. GaN but they may
be out of luck Lebanon has no intention
of extraditing him and the next chapter
of this story may be told by script
writers rather than in court
poor Kelso skynews